when i was the kid i drew all over the
wall with the marker i'm sure i had a
good reason although it escapes me now
but i did realize that i was gonna get
in a ton of trouble and so i hit on the
perfect alibi the easter bunny did it
that was airtight you can't poke holes
in that no one knows where the easter
bunny is
problem was my parents didn't believe in
the easter bunny anymore
i was busted
i learned a hard lesson that day about
the nature of magic
now sadly i'm an adult and i envy my
younger self the one who believed in
magic
did the wrinkles in gray hair grow an
inverse relationship to wonder
so what does the easter bunny have to do
with the bermuda triangle
we miss that wonder we long for a world
with magic in it
so here i am on the edge of a boat in
the bermuda triangle
and i'm hosting a tv show about curses
so maybe all hope isn't lost
there's a desire to believe in something
beyond our understanding
can a science minded skeptic like myself
reignite the spark of magic
is there an intersection point between
science and myth
wait what was that
dude that was a shark man
oh there he goes
there goes the genius
i used to be a professional sailor and
at some point i've crossed most of the
world's oceans on various sailboats
and i've seen some pretty strange things
cheers
if you want to hear some stories just
mix sailors and alcohol
and you'll turn on a spigot you wish you
could stop
who's got like a good bermuda triangle
story
one time we went out with a sonar placed
it at the bottom of the ocean and
something sent a magnetic field back up
but they said it was like almost
100 feet in the ground deep underneath
it yeah probably godzilla
they also have the vortex around you
right yeah what's the vortex it's a spot
where all the instruments go crazy and
it's like a portal to another dimension
or something
if you guys see anything like that on
here like weird
i mean there's no way sometimes
it'll be right there and then
i mean you guys all know um steve
knowles right like his story about they
were doing like 40 knots or so we had
three or four guys on the boat one green
light
came screaming up behind the boat and
then it came around to the side of the
boat they're still doing 40 knots lit up
the whole side of the boat and then they
say took off like a rocket in front of
them
yeah
that's crazy yeah
a story with everybody you know probably
the flight 19. what do you guys think
happened to flight 19 you know that's
fortunate five playing that does this
every day and then there's one day it
just disappears you know yeah a search
plane went out and also went missing
right and that was a sea plane yeah
why wouldn't a sea plane be able to line
yeah russia
right so
all a mystery
the story of the bermuda triangle really
has three chapters
plane crashes shipwrecks and the
mysterious disappearances of entire
cruise we call those ghost ships
but are any of these chapters truly
anomalous is the bermuda triangle more
dangerous than the rest of the world's
oceans
we'll analyze the planet's most infamous
curse with the skeptical forensic mind
so here it is this is the this is it
this is the bermuda triangle you know
florida bermuda to puerto rico
you know it's about 500 000 square miles
the fact is there have been countless
incidents millions on the world's oceans
since the first seafaring people set out
nearly 50 000 years ago
most of these are easy to explain
you know bad weather human error faulty
equipment
the ocean's a big bad place
but i'm interested in the events here
that have some mystery surrounding them
where it's harder to put your finger on
the cause
so i've hand selected some of the most
cryptic occurrences
and created incident maps of the areas
surrounding the bermuda triangle
you can see there's hundreds and
hundreds of shipwrecks
and uh
plane crashes
this cluster here has got to be flight
19.
the disappearance of flight 19 is the
foundation of the bermuda triangle
legend
in early december in 1945
five navy planes took off from florida
on a training mission with 14 men on
board
those planes the infamous flight 19
disappeared without a
trace but then one of the rescue planes
that goes looking for them also
completely vanishes
and now you have the seeds for a mystery
300 boats and planes searched the water
for five days not one shred of wreckage
was ever found
this concrete shipwreck off the coast of
bimini is the last witness to the
missing planes while it can't tell its
story in words i'd love to find some
shrapnel of evidence of what happened to
flight 19 something to ease my skeptic
mind and keep the hope for a magical
world alive
[Music]
this was
the target for flight 19 this is where
flight 19
is
[Music]
this
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as lovely as this location is as lucid
and clean the water
i can't help but think of the 27 young
men who flew over the stretch of
unforgiving ocean and vanished forever
in the darkness of the coming night
all those families ripped apart children
left behind without ever knowing what
happened without closure without
understanding
did those young men fall victim to a
mysterious geophysical curse
what happened out there in the darkness
[Music]
this is actually the lead ship of flight
19. wow the exact same plane as this is
flight 19. yes the final words of the
men on flight 19 have been studied and
poured over
every sentence and word analyzed in
depth by the navy's after action report
and then of course reanalyzed by
armchair historians and hacky cursed tv
shows
walk me through what happened to flight
19 what's the deal it was a training
flight for navigation training believe
it or not so we just got back from the
sapona which we we dove on that was
their target so we know they dropped
their bombs on the sapona right what was
their path after that due east to east
for another 60 70 miles okay then make a
turn to the north northwest what
happened it's a big mystery to this day
right nobody knows exactly what happened
to him
nobody knows but there are theories
colleen sterling is the lebron james of
aviation probability analysis you maybe
didn't know there wasn't lebron james of
that after two years of searching for
air france flight 447 colleen was
brought in as part of a small team to
re-analyze the data they found the
wreckage in less than five days
the first thing we did is looked at the
500-page navy report that came out the
communications all the radar hits that
they had and we wrote a chronology the
key transmissions
everything is map-based right so i'll
put like where they launched from and
the time and then i'll draw the line
where they were supposed to go and then
i can calculate with the wind and their
heading how long it should have taken
them to get to their first turn point
i thought about that first turn point
and then i said well where could they
have gone from there
they were trying to go back to the
northwest
but the wind was blowing them and they
may have not made the turn sharp enough
and might have gotten significantly
blown to a different heading
towers
what is your compass reading powers
i don't know where we are
must have gotten lost after that last
turn
mt-28 this is ft-74 what is your trouble
uh both my compasses are out and i'm
trying to find fort lauderdale florida
so this is the compass here that's the
magnetic that's the magnetic compass so
he would be looking at this what else
would he look at that and then he down
on his instrument panel you have what's
called the gyrocompass here that you set
this with this knob to agree with this
to agree with this bounces around sure
that one is very stable
taylor who's the flight lead was talking
about the compass didn't look right he
started to get confused but they know
they have to get back taylor thought
that they needed to fly to the northeast
because he thought they were over the
florida keys
how did you think it's very hard to
imagine him getting that lost he doesn't
seem to have his wits about him on this
flight then you hear them arguing on the
radio it's really sad right
we've just passed over a small island
and we have no other land in sight
turn on your emergency isf gear or do
you have it on
iff gear was off i'm turning it on now
what's the isf gear iffs an acronym for
identification friend or folk okay right
here for example see this says 1200 in
an iff they would have given him a code
to squawk to put
in there and they would be picked up on
their radar he didn't have it all he
didn't have it on should he have had it
on especially if i want help than
finding out where i am right
ft 28 to 9
one of the planes in the flight thinks
if we went 270 degrees we could hit
land 270 that's dude that's somebody
with a decent compass or somebody else
is like hey we just go 270 we're gonna
hit last time to get to their bombing
target they flew due east right well
just flight due west and they take it
back
right we'll hit land at some
point ft 28 all planes in flight change
course to 0.90 for one minute
so now they're going back east again
east again
damn if we just fly west you would get
home
hold it head
who is the ranking guy on the flight
he kept saying we need to go west right
and then it gets corroborated without
radar track that came from the solomon's
aircraft carrier and where did that see
them the radar tracks showed aircraft
going south
over land
there's a good chance that it could be
somewhere in this mid-peninsula east
coast of florida region so that wouldn't
surprise you at all no
the model supports that
wow
we are now flying 270 degrees we will
fly 270 degrees until we hit the beach
or run out of gas
[Music]
and now they know they're in trouble
because it's like time
and they just don't have a clue where
they are
when the first plane drops below 10
gallons we all go down together
does everyone understand that
in december of 1945 five planes flown by
navy pilots vanished into the night
then one of the rescue planes that went
after them suffered the same fate
collectively the strange event is known
as flight 19.
we've just passed over a small island
and we have no other land in sight it's
the single biggest event that gave the
cursed triangle its name but here's a
question what if the planes didn't
really go down inside the bermuda
triangle does the curse dissolve into
thin air
when the first plane drops below 10
gallons we all go down together
does everyone understand that
[Music]
there's a good chance that it could be
somewhere in this mid-peninsula east
coast of florida region they actually
could have made it back and started
heading south in the time that they had
before they ran out of fuel
wow
[Music]
for 70 years
this disappearance gripped the
imagination and
people assumed it crashed at sea and
what this model is showing me is there's
this whole other search area that no
one's even looked at there are still
corners of florida that nobody's been in
because it's inaccessible for one reason
or another
i don't usually follow up on leads when
they involve like some dude who heard
something from another guy who may or
may not have seen something
but colleen's identified a search zone
near a turtle preserve in central
florida
and there just happens to be a guy with
a story about a crashed airplane
how do you know that this is the plan
we're looking for of flight 19. well
john meyer one of the leading
researchers for flight 19 his theory was
that the five airplanes separated at
some point in time off the eastern coast
of florida when they were trying to find
land right when they got real low on
fuel right and john thought that ft-81
actually made it back over land right
and the diagram that he drew based on
his theory
put ft-81 in this particular area of
florida at about the time it ran out of
gas really
so we've been out here looking for this
particular wreck site for a while
because we've been out here trompering
around in basically everglades type of
conditions
as horrific and sad as it sounds planes
crash all the time if we find out where
any part of flight 19 actually went down
well then the planes didn't disappear at
all
and definitely not in the bermuda
triangle
and they're just part of a tragic list
with thousands and thousands of other
entries
when john passed away
we're not really sure what happened to
his notes and we had hurricane dorian
this fall and it really flooded the area
without john's notes we're looking for
the proverbial needle in the haystack
but we're not even sure which haystack
to look in
with colleen sterling confirming this
area as the most likely location that
flight 19 went down we decided to bring
in some technology to speed up the
search
so this is a lidar drone what does that
mean so it is a multi-rotor quadcopter
and it has a lidar unit on it right
basically the same principle as a
policeman with a speed gun shoots out a
laser hit something solid the return
comes back and then it highly accurately
marks those points millions of points of
rotation thousands of rotations a second
when it's all said and done mike he'll
filter it out so we can actually get the
vegetation away and look for the
impressions yeah well let's get it done
arming the props
all right taking off
since we have that high level of
accuracy all of those like bottom points
we're going to be really highly
confident that those are actually ground
that's what's going to you know allow us
to give you guys an awesome
representation of this landscape as if
we had just you know burned all the
vegetation down
so
basically what we're looking for is
artificial features right down here
is a nice little cross hmm see this
impression here that creates this line
it's pretty darn straight and then you
have another one right here
it's very unusual for a natural feature
to have such pretty geometry right i
think this is the best place to look for
this wreck
all right
straight ahead here
head a little bit left
we should be getting pretty close
there's a break in the weeds right there
there's something here what you got
something burned up oh yeah that's it
there we go
right that's got to be it that's that's
got to be it look
that would have been attached to the
back of an engine
there's the tire
cool
it came in pretty steep
there's all kinds of debris in there
that would have been the iff unit render
fro unit okay yeah iff gear was off i'm
turning it on now
we'll do the next step for you the rest
of the airplane is probably buried what
we're looking for is the data plate on
the front of the engine
but to dig in the wildlife management
area we have to have a separate permit
to do that but it is something that we
can come back and do
while we need a serial number to say if
this world war ii era wreck is one of
the planes from flight 19
there is a chance at least one of them
is not lost in the bermuda triangle at
all you know
this could be ft-81
which would mean some of them at least
made it back to line right the truth is
the psychological grip of the bermuda
triangle's curse extends well beyond six
missing planes
so while nate works on digging out the
engine block yeah i wouldn't want to be
the one i was hoping you would be good
my investigation moves to phase two
ghost ships
there comes a time in everyone's life
where you find yourself sitting in the
dark room at 3 a.m half-eaten turkey
sandwich typing or muted triangle
mysteries into the search engine
what you tend to find are long lists of
disappearances ships and planes
vanishing
and there's a list of theories that goes
along with it magnetic fields mermaids
gigantic undersea methane bubbles
but it goes
way out to alien wormholes and time
vortices atlantis were they sucked under
by the kraken now some of these theories
are fairly bonkers but others you know
they seem pretty plausible
and then sometimes you find something
that does seem real and fascinating and
truly inexplicable something that on the
surface defies any rational explanation
here's maybe the most interesting
incident map this is ghost ships
so ghost ships were ships that are just
floating drifting in the ocean with
nobody on them
and this is from the u.s hydrographic
survey they documented sixteen hundred
ghost ships
yeah there's something very sort of
eerie and terrifying in this idea of 600
ships out here and
you know you don't know what happened to
the crew i mean where did everybody go
or where are the bodies
how this is happening
during a seven-year survey starting in
1887 the u.s hydrographic office found
the existence of sixteen hundred ships
floating a sea without a single soul on
board
sixteen hundred floating ships and zero
sailors that mass seems off
now i'm not saying that it's not aliens
because it could be
but let's see how a scientist who
studies the world's oceans explains it
they call this area the um doldrums of
the doldrums the atmospheric circulation
starts with a lot of warm moist air
rising from the pacific in the tropical
area and once it reaches high altitudes
it starts heading toward the poles and
at a certain latitude which is in this
area
the air starts sinking yeah and
associated with them is very little wind
so
pre-19th century all the ships were
sails right so these sailboats required
wind to move right so it just sort of
sits there and it just sits there but
other things like large mats of
sargassum weed which are less buoyant
than water they float
you had these massive sargassum weed
that you just literally got stuck in
big mats 100 yards wide and almost a
mile long
wow
you're stuck yeah you imagine six weeks
of it or seven weeks of it running out
of water and you're hoping for some
winds you're hoping to find some current
yeah and hoping for something to blow
right wow
i can't imagine anything creepier than
running into a ship in the middle of
nowhere with nobody on it
what's your theory why would all these
boats end up empty there are some people
out there that believe aliens are
involved sure but you know i'm a
scientist i'm waiting to see the first
true documented case of the alien
abduction right but they do have these
uh ocean vortices if you got
coordinators you go oh great i'm i'm
finally going
but they spin around in the order of
nine ten days they basically bring you
back to the same location which would be
tough if you're running out of water
[Music]
and as you know if you drink salt water
over time makes you a little uh crazy
you get dehydrated hallucinate things
like that and that you know helps to add
all the great legends right about
mermaids and monsters and maelstroms and
the triangle and the bermuda triangle
[Music]
you can sort of imagine the mariners out
here
during the age of sale being stuck
but i think that's why sailors get so
superstitious
because they show a little control over
the weather
and so many things so you never sail on
a friday
you gotta be careful whistling on a boat
because you can whistle up a breeze
you know there's a
trillion sailor superstitions
and it probably comes from a sense of
powerlessness and being being trapped
we were in hamilton harbor in bermuda
and i was anchored there in an 85 foot
steel catch
the tail end of a hurricane came through
and we heard on the radio
six
vessels uh you know calling for help
abandoning ship
these were inexperienced sailors and to
them it felt like the world was ending
and water's coming in and you know it's
intense
you could hear on the radio fear
just warping their perception
[Music]
and putting them in a bad spot uh where
you know if they'd been through it one
time if they'd lived through it one time
they would have known they're gonna
survive it and that their other options
are worse
many times you know these vessels turn
up floating
and the crew died and they could have
stayed and they would have been wet and
miserable but they would have lived
listen inexperienced sailors make
mistakes
but for that to be replicated sixteen
hundred times
come on that's a mystery
humans are a complex animal and there's
a lot of variation within our species
if you walk down the street and go into
a bar or a grocery store
everybody acts different some people are
loud some are quiet some walk fast some
walk slow
but if something scary happens
then boom in the face of fear
instincts kick in and we all move in
unison
but is that enough to explain how 1600
crews of stranded sailors all repeated
the exact same behavior time after time
after time
dr george everly wrote the book on the
human stress response and you know
what's super stressful
abandoning ship
what would cause a seasoned
professional a professional sailor right
to
lose rationality
and abandon ship
now we do know extreme stress
does
allow a part of the brain to hijack your
more rational centers there's a part of
the brain called the amygdala yes and
the amygdala
is the home of what we sometimes call
the fight-or-flight response right every
once in a while the amygdala can hijack
executive functions it overrides it if
you will okay so we begin to do
irrational things and it begins mildly
irrational if i can drink some salt
water maybe it'll buy me enough time for
maybe a miracle
the brain is concerned about survival it
could lead one to do anything in a
moment of desperation
i'm dry that's wet i'll try it out so
going overboard seems like a really good
idea right until you go overboard and
find out it's not
your kidneys can only handle so much
salt in your diet and salt water from
the ocean has four times that amount
so drinking salt water basically starts
a doomsday clock in your body
the minute you take your first sip you
start dying
the marine corps came up with
conditioned black
catastrophic failure of your cognitive
abilities because of stress
you know the classic line from the rhyme
of the ancient mariner is water water
everywhere and not a drop to drink
it was a real thing
i think dehydration plays a bigger role
as dehydration gets into people they
start drinking salt water and eventually
they start getting off the boat
to me the ghost ships aren't some sort
of symptom of a cursed bermuda triangle
it's a weather pattern that causes ships
to get stuck
and then human instinct causes people to
make bad decisions
it's the perfect storm repeating over
and over maybe the real mystery isn't
some dark external force but something
inside of our own minds
maybe we're a species of mammal that was
never meant to be on the ocean at all
weird stuff has been happening in the
bermuda triangle for a long time
some people think it goes all the way
back to christopher columbus who saw
strange lights in the sky and he later
lost his flagship to santa maria
in the five century since countless
other ships have vanished in this 500
000 square mile stretch of ocean
but is there really something
supernatural happening here or is the
open ocean just a dangerous place to be
i'd really like to get into some of
these shipwrecks
i'm curious as to whether we can find
you know some kind of root cause
for this pattern of shipwrecks
you know it could be
currents it could be
shallow water in here this is all the
bahamas and there's a ton of huge
sections of one foot two foot sand banks
and all kinds of reefs that aren't even
marked today
and some of that might be the
explanation but
i think we need to dig a little deeper
an estimated three million shipwrecks
litter the ocean bottom
and less than one percent have ever been
explored
there are logical explanations for the
wrecks around bermuda the knife edge
reefs the high traffic even hurricanes
but most armchair bermuda triangle
experts will point to the more
mysterious events
like the disappearance of the uss
cyclops
the cyclops is the shipwrecks what
flight 19 is to plane crashes in march
of 1918 the last transmission the ship
sent on its way through the triangle
gave the impression of bright sunny
skies fair weather
and then
she disappeared without a trace
no distress call no sign of wreckage
309 men vanished
what do the conditions down there look
like they're good i mean you can
definitely see it's definitely snapped
in half there's the half of a wreck
sitting right on the bottom it's the
steering portion of it it was a shipping
boat that went down
in the early 90s
it's not the cyclops but neil found a
much more recent wreck that may offer a
clue
a ship that appears to be snapped in
half
you said it was the tail end of
hurricane andrew it was shortly after
the hurricane they were bringing
supplies there's nothing to hit out here
knows what happened yeah who knows
it took a little while for us to find it
but we fixed a mooring on it and
just a temporary chain and line that
will follow down
[Music]
so if i don't make it back
tell my mom i love her okay you guys
thanks i have your partners yes no no
come on no no
none of you get my barneys
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unexpectedly
[Music]
nobody knows quite what happened because
something broke the hips backward
i can understand how bad weather can
make a ship size or a torpedo or boiler
room explosion could knock a hole in the
side
but to crack so cleanly in half
how would that happen
and could this be a clue as to how the
cyclops and so many other ships have
been lost
[Music]
tim jansen is a physical oceanographer
and he has a scientific theory that
might explain all these sudden
disappearances
it's something i heard rumors about when
i was sailing around the world in my 20s
the terrifying rogue wave
what's your definition of a rogue wave
the general definition everybody
understands it's a very very big wave
and then there's a sort of like
scientific version of that
which doesn't like big or large because
it's not very precise okay so you
measure for a while you pick the highest
one-third of the waves you average that
number and that's the significant wave
height a wave that is twice as big as
that that's formerly called
a rogue wave right so drop no wave is
the first time that we actually measured
a wave that was qualifying as a little
roadway like you know two times a
significant wave height in an already
very large wave field where was it what
was it this was in uh off the coast of
norway the north sea when was that this
was 1995. so pretty recently like
they've only had a real scientific proof
of any of this totally 95.
for centuries the scientific community
wrote off the concept of rogue waves as
just tall tales told by drunken sailors
exaggerations that are unreliable
then in the mid 90s the dropner oil
platform was being battered by some
run-of-the-mill 40-foot waves when a
monster came out of nowhere nearly 90
feet tall a rogue wave smashed into the
dropner oil platform
recently a nasa study determined that at
any given time there are as many as 10
rogue waves happening in the world's
oceans
most people were sort of like discarding
that as sort of like you know mermaid
type stories right a rogue wave is rare
but it's not impossible like you know
three and ten thousand right you know
100 foot wave we see them all the time
really
when i got out of college i was at a
loss i didn't have a plan but then an
old family friend offered me a job
fixing up a yacht and then sailing
around the world i mean he was gonna pay
me well i knew that opportunity could
never come again so i kept my mouth shut
and he never realized how clueless i was
and i took the job
three and a half years in the ocean will
teach you a lot
but luckily during all that time we
never hit one of these
a rogue wave is rare but it's not
impossible like you know three and ten
thousand right you know a hundred foot
wave we see them all the time really
now i've never myself as an adult but if
i was sailing along and i looked up into
the shadow of an eight-story high wave
that might be the time
if you have a significant wave height of
say 17 18 meters that means that in that
wave field there's going to be waves
it's going to be way bigger than that
they have to be there has to be a wave
twice that absolutely otherwise you
wouldn't get an average of 17 meters
yeah yeah
wow that's a lot of water man it is
okay here's where we get to the good
part
you're on your freighter and you're in a
storm
and a hundred foot wave
is coming at you from some unknown
direction what kind of things might
happen
a single large wave could put stresses
on a vessel that you normally wouldn't
have you would have like just one very
big wave say in the middle of the vessel
lifting it up
and you have two sides that aren't
supported putting a lot of stress in the
middle
and that's how a 550 foot long steel
ship snaps in half
just like a baseball bat over bo
jackson's knee
how cool was bo jackson by the way
whether or not boats disappear because
of roadways undoubtedly yes right um how
often we don't know sure and whether or
not all these vessels are due to
roadways i think that question is open
yeah no i mean it's like the mystery of
the sea right there's a lot of unknowns
out there still
a curse can be a powerful weapon for
those who lack power
a supernatural vow to take revenge
beyond the plane we exist in but the
bermuda triangle isn't a singular event
brought on by magic or an angry voodoo
priest
is something in the collective
consciousness an agreement made by
millions of strangers as a way to
explain the inexplicable there are
plausible scientific explanations for
all these events that have given the
bermuda triangle its mythical cursed
status and i know i'm not smarter than
those who believe i mean ask my sixth
grade teacher mr dowsky and she'll tell
you so why do so many people believe
that it's cursed when science says
there's nothing special about this area
so michael i've been doing some
investigation and i know you've written
about this so
the bermuda triangle
what do you think our brains are not
well wired to understand randomness our
brains are wired to find patterns and
meaning hidden forces at work conspiracy
somebody is behind the scenes pulling
the strings and reproductive success is
the key to evolution so we are the
descendants of those who are most likely
to find meaningful patterns right and
infuse those patterns with agency
yeah let's look at some of these
examples here
when you set out to make a documentary
you're filled with hope that all this
cool stuff is gonna happen
you're gonna find out that magic is real
and then you're forced to confront
reality
the world k is your b bro and you run
into that one guy at the bar and he
ruins everything we're looking at uh you
know regional shipwreck data since 2007
and of course you would expect it you
know in the pacific ocean and you know
the indian ocean and so on but but
here's our triangle right does it seem
to be
going on there right in other words the
number of accidents here in the bermuda
triangle doesn't even reach this level
of the bay of bengal right and you know
who knows the statistics insurance
companies right people who have to pay
out if there's a crash or some kind of
financial loss and they don't charge
anymore to travel through the bermuda
triangle right if there was something
happening the insurance companies would
100 billion trillion percent make you
pay more they're not going to lose money
like that's not happening there's no way
that's right yeah
so the reality is crossing the atlantic
anywhere would be just as dangerous as
going through the bermuda triangle
and yet the name the bermuda triangle
has terrified generations of non-sailors
but why
so where does the term bermuda triangle
come from the origin myth begins in the
early 1960s with an article
by a guy named vincent gattis in the
magazine argosy
argosy was one of the largest pulp
fiction magazines ever published fiction
okay that's it fiction right that's your
first first clue right and he was basing
it on a fake magazine article yeah that
referenced this area around bermuda it
might be triangular so he called the
bermuda triangle and that meme really
stuck
and that's where the fantasy and
imagination jumps in especially fantasy
writers charles burlitz for example he
was very popular writer he wrote books
on roswell
he jumped right in with the bermuda
triangle and that's what kind of put it
on the map right
some riders go all goes back to columbus
columbus saw all kinds of crazy you know
those guys crossing the ocean they saw
lots totally of course and what do they
know exactly
ask any bermuda triangle enthusiast and
they'll tell you that christopher
columbus was the first person to write
about mysterious forces in the triangle
apparently he saw a series of lights
dancing in the sky
this could be the genesis of the
triangle's larger than life reputation
every curse every myth every mystery has
a moment where it began
a singular point in the space-time
continuum from which everything else
follows was the bermuda triangles moment
in a place just like this 528 years ago
columbus
he was coming in to the caribbean and
possibly san salvador
and
he recounted
seeing
lights hovering in the sky
you know in some ways the bermuda
triangle goes back
to that
story that's the first mysterious
incident
armchair bermuda triangle theorists
often point to this sighting as evidence
of something supernatural
but is there something else going on
here san salvador's got indigenous
people latino people that might have had
fires on a hillside and it's possible
that columbus mistook
fires on a hillside
or something else
so i think i'm gonna go up there and
build a fire and we'll pull out and see
what it looks like
it's not exactly hard science but my
time machine only goes back to 1493
and this is the best we can do
so people
when they see something they don't
understand they make up a myth
mythology superstition curses are ways
of dealing with uncertainty
the bermuda triangle weird stuff happens
here
but it could be that columbus just saw
something as simple as this
you know a fire on a hillside
so we'll take a boat out and
look back at this and say
would you have been fooled
so we're not exactly sure where columbus
was when he saw lights in the sky
and anyone who says they know for sure
is full of it
and a sample of 10 articles about
columbus sighting will give you 10
different interpretations of what
happened
but that's irrelevant because even
though that event is pointed to as the
origin of the bermuda triangle's
supernatural power
the point isn't to perfectly recreate a
well-documented historical event it's to
see if columbus's mysterious light could
have been caused by something extremely
unmysterious that's a word by the way
that's the fire
i said earlier on the hill
columbus has done the unthinkable he's
crossed the ocean
he's been at sea for months he was all
the way in the caribbean even though you
know he thought he was in indonesia
and he sees
lights
floating in the sky
one man's sighting of lights in the sky
is another man's proof of the
supernatural but this happened 500 years
ago so it's probably worth asking the
question what did columbus actually see
well his journal says it looked like
candlelight rising up and down
look familiar
when we run out of
rational understanding when we can't
explain something to ourselves
we look for causation
quite possibly columbus was just so
fried
and it had been so long that he couldn't
see
what was there
he might have seen
what is behind me right now for a lot of
people that's where the bermuda triangle
myth starts all the way back to columbus
he was lost and something as simple as
some indigenous people starting a fire
on a hill could be the origin of the
bermuda triangle
columbus jotted it in a journal and then
people played the telephone game for
five centuries
the lights in the sky the promise of
land in the distance
turned into indisputable evidence of the
supernatural for those who wanted to
believe
[Music]
occam's razor says that the simplest
explanation is usually correct and yet
when it comes to catastrophe or death
the terrifying unknown we rarely accept
the low-hanging fruit if ships disappear
well maybe it's aliens when planes
disappear obviously there's a vortex to
another dimension
hey samus nate we were able to id that
plane we found but it's not from flight
19.
turns out it's a different world war two
airplane
it's a farmer but the search continues
all right so we didn't solve a 75 year
old mystery in the two weeks we had to
film this show
but still when it comes to the bermuda
triangle there is no curse
if there was some statistical measurable
impact then we would see it in insurance
rates and maritime practice and in
government orders
believing in the supernatural stretch of
ocean is a little like believing in the
easter bunny and we want magic in the
world we need it
if some older kid tells your toddler the
truth about a certain magical holiday
you get enraged
because the world is a better place with
magic in it
the curse of the bermuda triangle is a
sociological construct
not a marine confluence and in some ways
it speaks to man's need for myth for
gods for devils
and for the unknown to remain unknowable
[Music]
you